listen folks if you're looking forward
to thanksgiving uh you may want to uh
start shopping early and maybe even uh
have a couple turkeys in the back now to
be ready for it because things are going
up your prices price wise okay biden
inflation thanksgiving meal said to be
the most expensive uh on record the
post-millennial story after supply and
chain crunches and an undeniable
increased food cost americans are facing
a huge increase in cost for their
traditional thanksgiving meal the new
york times reported that thanksgiving
2021 could be the most expensive meal in
the history of holidays the biden
administration made an enormous deal
about how americans fourth of july
barbecues were 16 cent less than they
were in 2021 the administration was
widely
mocked for their tweet touting this less
than impressive decline in food cost the
biden administration was so pleased with
itself that they actually posted about
how great it was that americans would
save 16 cents on their meals well that's
not going to be happening thanksgiving
so profound what what do you have to say
about this uh danielle
this is
i look i've got four kids and i know
what groceries cost and i can tell you
they cost more and more and more every
time i'm at the store and then the
packages are getting smaller which
really pisses you off you know what the
box of cereal size is supposed to be
when you buy as many boxes of cereals as
as i do so it is it's the most grating
thing and then god forbid the gas tanks
on empty and then you got to go fill up
and you're like okay what's up with this
price per gallon seriously so i just
came back from europe i was i was over
there and i mean they're paying like
seven bucks a gallon
for what yes
seven bucks a gallon for gas in europe
yeah
it's kind of it's going to come ten
dollars coming here soon by the way but
i mean but the whole the whole idea and
you know and so i was in a socialist
country italy is a socialist extremely
and there is so much resentment right
now they're rolling out a tax for the
winter time to have the the people of
means pay for the the higher electricity
prices for the people who of of not of
lower means
so they just tax the hell out of you
left right and in between but no i'm
look i'm a working mom but the grocery
store's gotten to be too expensive so so
you guys have stopped eating we're
having to do what you got to do we're
having we're having chicken nuggets
for thanksgiving you know what is crazy
though everybody at this table you're
not struggling financially i remember
when we did as a family
and we were a welfare family and uh
nobody was working my dad worked at a 99
cent store there was nothing going on
you felt
a slight price increase because you
would hear it from your mom when she
said we can't afford that right now what
are you talking about we can't afford it
right now there's going to be millions
of families that are going to feel it
directly not only thanksgiving
they're going to feel it christmas these
are too bad to back that's going to be
felt and it's emotional and it's painful
and it sticks as a kid you remember 30
years later what it was like at a
christmas or thanksgiving when you were
broke millions are going to feel that
this is giving you you feel it in every
direction too because it's not just that
thanksgiving dinner then it's you can't
afford to go to the movies and then the
gas is more expensive then you might not
be able to afford that cell phone plan
and then you can't get school shopping
done or the thing so it's everywhere and
that's what inflation is and that's what
we're all gonna experience pretty soon
when i heard this story the first thing
that came to my mind with bite inflation
is hunter biden he's going to do an nft
you know of of of this of the phrase and
he's going to get a ukrainian
businessman to open up a boutique and
then he's going to sell them all he's
going to market that and capitalize on
bite inflation the name
so you know that they're proud of that
right you know you know he sold a bunch
of a piece of art last week at like 75
thousand dollars and one of the ladies
who was there she says i went there they
wouldn't even let me in because she's a
critic of art and they said you can't
come in here she said i went across the
street and they were selling a picasso
painting original sign for four hundred
thousand dollars so would you rather
spend four hundred thousand dollars for
an original because you're paying for
75 grand what kind of political interest
back to your lower income families and
and and christmas and the holiday season
uh deloitte published a survey last week
the average american family that's lower
income is spending 22 percent less on
christmas this year the average wealthy
american family is spending 15 percent
more so when you print money and it all
floats up to the top and then inflation
hurts everybody at the bottom i mean
this is this is a train wreck but that's
that's the biggest thing where it's like
the people that are voting to send more
free money are the ones that end up
paying the biggest price
it is so freaking weird the basics of
math like this thing doesn't favor you
the more money they print every time
danielle they printed more money i made
so much money i can't even tell you how
much money i make every time that's
where it flows it shows up because they
don't know how so so anyway so that
concept basic concept so let me say that
number one more time so the the low
income family is going to spend 20 to 20
less during christmas holiday season
than last holiday season though the
wealthy is going to spend 15 percent
more
that's that's amazing if they could get
the stuff they want to buy right just
think of you shopping early you know
this is this is private jets this is
flying off no i'm talking about renting
nice houses i'm talking about the lower
income people that they will even want
to buy the christmas gifts they might
not be available right the toys aren't
even out there well no and you had was
was it hasbro there was some major toy
company that came out a few days ago
that basically said you know like we're
down like a third in terms of the
inventory that we need
the containers are sitting out there in
the water
that's great baby if you're listening
buy the gifts nowadays
dylan's going to be complaining planning
pre-planning the i think the biggest
thing that frustrates me with reading
something like this is just seeing the
hypocrisy in terms of how they're how
they're parading 16 cents in july and
then now it's backfiring of like how
they're trying to push that up one thing
if they were like you know what
inflation is happening we're working on
it we're trying to figure it out it's
gonna get bad before it gets better
right it's gonna get worse before it
gets better but instead of them trying
to parade with hey we saved you 16 cents
over a full fourth of july barbecue to
now coming back i think that's more
where yeah it upsets me in terms of them
trying to parade something very small
make it look like a big win
not realizing that a bigger loss is
going to come down the pipeline and
that's just going to be more upsetting
on that that's a really good point
because it just shows how stupid they
think we are like we're going to get
excited about saving 16 cents on the
fourth of july how do you even compute
that you can't it makes no sense it's
not even a rounding statement you want
to hear who's right who's the marketer
first of all you never say
16 cents you say
americans are gonna save you know nine
point three billion dollars and yeah
even the even the basis
multiply it times 335 million people
just give a number to it rather than
what the hell is 16 cents right when's
the last time even kept change so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]